all right the nfl has a pre-season
problem
in so far as the preseason is too long
and the linkage of shortening the
preseason and expanding the regular
season diminishing the connection
between shortening the preseason and
expanding the playoffs gaining momentum
mark mask of the washington post had a
story on wednesday chris that expanded
playoffs a more likely replacement for
part of the pre-season than expanded
regular season we talked about expanded
playoffs yesterday i know you're not a
fan of them but you know one thing i
want to make clear the nfl has the
ability to shrink the pre-season anytime
they want they just don't want to do it
without a way to offset the revenue they
will lose of course and they they seem
to think they can expand the playoffs
without the consent of the nflpa they're
wrong on that or they would have done it
already the nfl players association has
to agree to the addition of games even
if it's only two more games now i
personally think if you're gonna have
extra games in the wild card round and
make the two seed play the seventh seed
who currently doesn't get in i think the
eighth seed needs to be in and the one
seed needs to play that weekend i don't
like the idea of only one team per
conference getting a bye making that
advantage even stronger making that one
seed even more valuable making the
presumption even stronger that the one
seed is going to the super bowl i don't
like that i say if you're going to
expand it expand it to 16 make the one
seed play wild card round and uh and
have
four extra wild card games not two chris
what do you think well i mean i don't
really necessarily like that i don't i
mean first off then
you know yeah i mean
what what's the why do you even want to
be the one seed really i mean okay i
mean i just did that's a great you play
the eighth seed and the eight seeds the
worst team in the playoffs okay great i
mean so what i mean
some teams might go damn that looks like
the seven teams worse than the eight
team let's let's be the two seed you
know there's got to be some reward for
winning the regular season more than
just that itself uh and i do think that
i i of course like the current status
and i don't like the no buy thing no
that's yes it's an advantage for the
teams that have the buy i get that
they've earned it by winning in the
regular season and and now they get a
week of rest to be at their absolute
best that's everybody else's fault
that's not their fault so i don't
necessarily like that i would like to
find it you know if we're gonna do it i
saw one explanation of maybe
all four
division winners get a bye on the first
weekend and then the five through eights
kind of play each other and then they
figure out how to match and mix and
match the next offs you know next round
however maybe either way i don't want to
see it before i confuse this situation
but wait wait wait wait that's not going
to create more games in the wild card
round you're going to have okay you're
going to have five through eight in each
conference play each other in the wild
card round you still have the same
number of games uh yeah no i know it's
not gonna it's still gonna have the same
number of games but at least there's a
reward for some teams to win the
division and get a first round bye i
mean i am in favor of that first off
second off i don't want it anyways oh
you're wait you're talking about an
extra round right you're talking about
uh uh okay so there would be
there would be a pre-wild card round
where five through eight whittle them
down to two teams and then you start
with the normal wild card round then the
division you know it's an extra week of
football here's the thing
it adds an extra week and it pushes the
super bowl one week closer to
president's day weekend which the nfl
would love to do and maybe maybe the
ultimate end result here is two
preseason games 17 regular season games
and that five through eight extra round
of the wild card a pre-wild card round i
kind of like that
uh but then here's what happens yeah
here's here's what happens the one in
the two seed chris end up getting two
bucks
yes i know and that i don't even know if
that's a good thing either weeks without
playing games i know that's scary that's
scary so yeah i mean i guess i have to
like
you know
work this through my brain a little but
also what i'm scared of is just a
watered down product to a degree a
little bit you know there's been years
where i just go you know i know we've
had years where the six seeds been
phenomenal we've seen the succeed win
the super bowl go to the super bowl do
all those things and yes but there's
been other years where i think we all go
damn the sixth seed they stink the five
seed they stink they have no chance so
five six seven and eight i want to go i
don't even want to see them this is a
waste of time and that's what i worry
about too a little bit so that's my
thought yeah you're letting half the
league into the playoffs how many is too
many and if you got 32 teams is 16 too
many uh and and that's why i think if
they do it it's going to be 14. they're
going to add two extra wild card games
they will be and and i think what they
need to do is take advantage of monday
night play one of those wild card games
on monday night and make sure that
whoever wins doesn't play until the
following sunday so they at least have
you know some rest right before they
play their next game or or or have that
winner play the following monday but if
they want to generate the revenue the
kind of revenue that's going to offset
the loss of the preseason they need to
take full advantage of the prime time
windows and they're currently staying
away from monday night they need to
embrace sunday night and saturday night
as much as they possibly can in the wild
card round
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports